supongamos que tenemos una
circunferencia que en esta
circunferencia trazamos un diámetro más
o menos algo así algo así
déjame indicar que es un diámetro estoy
aquí es un diámetro
diámetro
y que tomamos otro punto más sobre la
circunferencia o sea que caiga en la
orillita
un punto por ahí y que dibujamos este
triángulo vamos a poner este lado y este
lado de acá lo que vamos a mostrar es
que no importa donde haya elegido este
punto siempre y cuando éste sea un
diámetro nos queda que el triángulo
siempre va a ser un triángulo rectángulo
déjame escribir eso por acá lo que vamos
a ver es que este triángulo este
triángulo siempre es un triángulo
rectángulo
vamos a probar esto déjame dibujar este
segmento de acá porque eso va a ser útil
y déjame indicar que este ángulo mide
theta vamos a ponerle que este ángulo de
acá me de teta bueno vamos a jugar un
poco con los ángulos para ver qué pasa
si este ángulo de acá me de teta como es
un ángulo inscrito correspondiente a
este ángulo central este ángulo de acá
mide dos tetas dos teta
son ángulos correspondientes o bueno
este central es el correspondiente a
este inscrito porque ambos abren este
arco de acá vale este arco y este arco
de acá y como vimos en vídeos pasados
eso implica que el ángulo central mide
el doble que el inscrito ahora notemos
que este lado que voy a marcar en color
rosa es un radio de la circunferencia y
este lado de acá también es un radio de
la circunferencia entonces si tomamos
este triángulo es un triángulo isósceles
déjame girarlo para que veas es un poco
más claramente este lado lo voy a poner
por acá
este lado lo voy a poner por acá y este
lado que es amarillo lo voy a poner por
acá entonces esos dos lados que pintan
en color rosa miden lo mismo por lo
tanto sus ángulos correspondientes
también son iguales este ángulo es igual
a este ángulo de acá ahora aquí no
tenemos un nombre para ese ángulo ya
utilice teta así que déjame ponerle no
sé digamos x este ángulo le vamos a
poner x entonces justo como es un
triángulo isósceles este de acá también
es equis y a partir de esto podemos
poner a equis en términos de teta usando
la suma de los ángulos internos de un
triángulo tenemos que x mas x + 2 teta
es igual a 180 grados lo voy a poner por
acá x más x más dos veces teta
dos veces teta teta es igual a 180
grados 180 grados x x es igual a 2 x 12
x es igual a entonces me quedaría 180
grados menos dos veces teta reste dos
tetas de ambos lados y dividiendo entre
dos de ambos lados aquí se cancela este
se cancela y éste nos quedan 90 grados
de modo que x es el 90 que era un poco
un poco escondido de modo que x es igual
a 90 grados 90 grados menos theta vamos
a pasar esto a la figura x es igual a 90
grados menos que está muy bien vamos a
ver qué otra cosa podemos hacer en esta
figura a ok tenemos que este es un radio
y que este es un radio pero también el
de acá es un radio porque también va del
centro de la circunferencia a la orilla
entonces este de acá también mide un
radio de todos estos son iguales a un
radio de modo que este triángulo de acá
también es y sociales de hecho eso es
algo
que utilizamos cuando mostramos que el
central media el doble del inscrito
entonces si éste si sos el es este
ángulo theta es igual a este ángulo teta
de acá este ángulo teta de acá sale y
entonces ya podemos calcular la medida
total de este ángulo de este ángulo
déjame hacerlo en color rojo color rojo
todo este ángulo de acá este ángulo está
formado por uno que mide teta con uno
que mide 90 grados menos theta 90 grados
menos theta entonces la medida de ese
gran ángulo justo es igual a 90 grados y
de 90 grados y por lo tanto este
triángulo es un triángulo rectángulo en
donde el ángulo recto es opuesto al
diámetro de la circunferencia es un
resultado súper padre y es bastante
general en realidad este punto lo
pudimos haber tomado en cualquier lado y
de todas formas nos quedaba un triángulo
rectángulo pudo haber sido por ejemplo
un punto por acá un punto por acá y
entonces tendríamos que este triángulo
rectángulo
este triángulo rectángulo con este el
ángulo recto
o bien pudimos haber tomado el punto por
acá y entonces este triángulo de acá es
el rectángulo con este de acá el ángulo
recto vale y la prueba sería exactamente
la misma para todos los casos bueno este
es un resultado muy bonito espero que te
haya gustado y nos vemos en siguientes
vídeos